je peux vous affirmer la cette fois ci
que je n'ai aucun mea culpa affaires
n'ai aucun remords ni aucun constat
d'échec
nous avons eu raison de le faire je suis
vraiment désolé pour tous les français
c'est que la réalité me semble que ce
que vous payez en match on avait prévu
[Musique]
et pas que du corps médical fait on va
dire de la politique c'est qu'on a des
patients à prendre en charge et
qu'actuellement on sait plus faire parce
que on a quasiment plus de capacité de
mutation de nos patients en riant tous
les leaders et à son plat mais dans tous
les cas cette marge de manoeuvre
on en a qu on en a pas en partie
[Musique]
on craint que ce soit extrêmement dur on
s'attend à ce que le mois de mars soit
très dur sur la vp des mesures de
confinement strict la poussière semaine
on serait absolument pas dans le
désastre sanitaire on va vivre
[Musique]
je peux vous le dire nous avons eu
raison de ne pas confiner la france à la
fin du mois de janvier
parce qu'il n'ya pas eu l'explosion qui
était prévu par tous les modèles
moi j'ai l'impression que le
gouvernement a parlé de prendre des
décisions contraignantes
sinon on l'aurait il aurait déjà pelle
je suis pas sûr pourquoi je vais médecin
quand on dit que ça va s'aggraver
[Musique]